to shorten our interview to take our
viewers to Washington DC because Donald
Trump the former U.S president is about
to touch down in the city Donald Trump
will be appearing before a federal
Magistrate
where we will formally he will be
formally charged on four counts
including conspiracy to defer the United
States consputee to obstruct an official
proceeding obstruction of and attempted
obstruction of official proceedings and
conspiracy against rights this is a
hugely historic moment for the United
States the third criminal indictment
against Trump
and of course the most grave relating to
when he was serving as president accused
of overturning the 2020 election results
that inspired the later events around
the Capitol building the Insurrection on
January the 6th
if you've just joined us you are looking
at Donald Trump's plane as it has
touched down it's made the short
45-minute Journey from Bedminster and
New Jersey where Trump has a resort we
expect him to get off the plane and make
the short drive towards the federal
magistrates
and we expect the hearing to be pretty
short as well it's an opportunity for
him to hear the charges against him
and to potentially make a plea whether
or not he will speak or whether he'll
speak through his lawyer all of those
questions will be answered soon but what
the prosecutors hope is that this will
pave the way
for a trial at some point which would be
an opportunity for
an array of of witnesses to appear
potentially also his former vice
president Mike Pence this is also very
much a stress test of the American
judicial system in a country where Trump
has continued to insist that the
elections of 2020 were stolen
and just to add according to latest
figures at least three in ten Americans
also believe that to be the case as well
the indictment is the product of months
of Investigations in which the special
counsel Jack Smith who is a career
prosecutor looked into the January 6
insurrection
at the U.S capital
and during the process of compiling the
indictment Smith seam questioned several
high-profile members of Trump's Inner
Circle including his son-in-law Jared
Kushner a former White House
communications director
hope Hicks you are looking at live
pictures of Donald Trump's aircraft you
can see the Trump name of course
emblazoned on the side of the plane as
it taxi is across the runway their short
Journey will be then made to the federal
magistrates where he'll be formally
charged on four counts
just repeat with those four counts are
conspiracy to Deford the United States
conspiracy to obstruct an official
proceeding obstruction of an attempt to
obstruct an official proceeding and
conspiracy
against rights we'll obviously be
following this to its conclusion over
the course of the day
okay it's time for sport now and the
latest from the Women's World Cup here's
Rahul Neve thank you very much we've
seen more history at the Women's World
Cup today debut since Morocco have
become the first Arab or North African
side to reach The Knockout stages
they've qualified for the last 16 at the
expense of two-time winners Germany who
are out well all four teams in Group H
still has a chance to go through at the
start of play Morocco were up against
Colombia in Perth and needed to better
the result of Germany who are playing
South Korea in Brisbane the Germans
playing a South Korean team remember
that had yet to record a single point at
this world cup well despite they're all
full form heading into the match it was
the South Koreans who got the very first
goal of the day
putting them ahead against Germany in
just the sixth minute the pressure was
now on the Germans who were heading out
at that stage but they did manage to
equalize just before half-time their
inspirational Captain Alexandra pop
scoring her fourth goal in three games
to make it one one and they are back on
track to go through
but then it swung back in Morocco's
favor when they were awarded a penalty
after a Columbia foul in the Box the
initial shot was saved but Anisa La
Marie reacted fastest to score off the
rebounds Morocco will one nil up and
once again they were heading into the
last 16 as things stood
or back in Brisbane pop nearly rescued
Germany again the German captain got the
ball over the line but was it ruled out
by VAR for offside then she headed
against the crossbar they kept pushing
but it was still all square and Germany
was still heading out of the World Cup
and in Perth Morocco's game finished
with them winning one nil but they faced
an anxious way watching the Germany game
on their phones and the celebration
started as soon as news came through the
Germans had failed to get the winner the
two-time World Cup winners and second
ranked team in the world knocked out at
the group stage for the very first time
in their history as for Morocco who were
beaten sixth nil by Germany in their
opening game or they become only the
eighth dividend team to reach the last
16.
so here's how the last 16 games shape up
Switzerland up against Spain and Japan
versus Norway Kingston kicks things off
on Saturday and on Sunday it's the
Netherlands against South Africa and
then defending Champions USA take on
Sweden into Monday European Champions
England faced Nigeria and Carol House
Australia are up against Denmark there
it is and then on Tuesday it's Colombia
against Jamaica and France up against
Morocco the country that knocked them
out of the men's World Cup last year in
Qatar
now nearly crowned formerly world
champion Jake Dennis says he's open to
competing to Formula One in the future
the Avalanche Andretti driver became the
first ever British Formula E world
champion this past weekend in London
which was staging the season finale
Dennis has been a test driver for F1
team Red Bull has been speaking to Al
Jazeera Sahel Malik about his Triumph
and his future
it was obviously a really incredible
achievement of obviously what we've left
London with
um there's uh yeah the emotions I felt
on Sunday uh and Saturday really uh was
was pretty special to obviously share it
with my team all the hard work
everything what went into the whole
season
was just something I'll never forget you
know it still gives me goosebumps now
thinking about it now Jake you join a
list of elite British world champion
drivers likes the Lewis Hamilton Colin
McRae Nigel Mansell who are the drivers
that have inspired you on your road to
becoming a world champion
when I was younger I actually never
really had too many inspirational people
to like look up to I always try to like
be my own person uh so I actually didn't
really ever Inspire to be you know the
next Lewis Hamilton or
um yeah Niger mans or anything like this
but I think as I got older I started to
learn a little bit more about I think
James Hunt I think he was a a really
cool racing driver you know he took he
enjoyed life he didn't take racing too
seriously I would say if I had to choose
anyone it would be more along his lines
but nevertheless
um yeah I always tried to choose my own
journey and not really
yeah tried to copy anyone else now
Andretti autism have been pushing to be
part of Formula One if that happens is
joining their Formula One team something
that would appeal to you I mean it's
definitely an interesting topic uh for
sure I think you know I think if the
opportunity came about it would be
definitely something to consider uh you
know but nevertheless I don't think it's
always
the best thing to do to go into Formula
One you know you've seen that the likes
of Nick the frizz who didn't have the
best of cars and then
it's then very easy to be forgotten
about and you know you're only as good
as your last race in Motorsports but you
know I am obviously uh very interested
in Formula One it's something which I've
always been involved in something which
from such a young age I think everyone
is involved in and
um it would appeal to me but yeah I
wouldn't make any Rush decision to to
jump directly into it
well the LA Lakers jersey worn by Wilt
Chamberlain the 1972 NBA Finals is to be
auctioned the Hall of Fame player wore
it when he scored 24 points and 29
rebounds against the New York Knicks
despite having a broken hand to lead the
Lakers to their first ever NBA title
bidding starts later this month and the
Jersey is expected to fetch more than
four million dollars
and finally Somalia Sports Minister has
apologized after an untrained Sprinter
was sent out to represent the country at
the world University games in China
well footage of the runner in line three
has gone viral and caused deep
embarrassment to the country she
finished 10 seconds behind the winner of
the 100 meters it's alleged that she
only competed because she's a relative
of the chairwoman of somalia's Athletics
Federation Sports Ministry has called
for the chairwoman to be suspended
and that is already sport for now I'll
have more later Dave all right many
thanks to that Raul
okay
you are watching Al Jazeera live from
Doha we can take you to some live
pictures in Washington DC where we are
waiting for Donald J Trump to make his
way down the steps of his aircraft he's
made the short Journey only 45 minutes
or so from his Resort in Bedminster New
Jersey
and he will be appearing before a
federal magistrate he is being charged
or going to be charged rather on four
counts accused of overturning the 2020
election results this airport of course
Arlington Virginia
he'll then of course make the short
Journey to the court the hearing is
meant to be very short indeed a chance
for him to hear the charges read out
there will is very likely to be a plea
then whether that is through his lawyer
whether he will have a chance to speak
all of these questions will be answered
soon but answering hopefully some of the
most pressing questions Alan Fisher who
joins us from outside the federal
courthouse and uh Alan as I said there
we're waiting for Donald Trump to emerge
on the top of the stairs leaving his
aircraft
the airport there in Arlington Virginia
talked us through the choreography of
this brief court appearance and its
significance in U.S political history
well he'll he'll get into his motorcade
it will drive the the five kilometers uh
from so we've had a number of people who
have been protesting there's a gentleman
here which you can't quite see but he's
wearing his striped suit in the form of
a 1930s movie convict this is a
gentleman who was there in Miami he
actually ran in front of Donald Trump's
motorcade as it left and he was taken to
the ground by secret service and he
later appeared in court as well Donald
Trump is a five kilometer drive from
Ronald Reagan National Airport to here
at the courthouse now normally at this
time of day in Washington that could
take you quite a while but it helps if
you're a former president who's on his
way to court because there will be a
motorcade that will escort him all the
way clearing the path so it should take
no more than 10 15 minutes to get here
he'll be taken into an underground
entrance in one of the corners of the
courthouse he will then be taken to be
processed he will give his name he will
hand over his Social Security security
number and his occupation presidential
candidate former president of the United
States of America he will be
fingerprinted there will be no picture
perp walk for him no cameras in federal
court here in the United States he will
then go into the court with his lawyers
at the four charges three of conspiracy
one of obstruction will be read out
he'll be asked if he understands the
charges and then asked if he wants to
plead almost certainly or plead not
guilty to the charge now we also know
that Donald Trump could have done this
over Zoom but opted not to he wanted to
come to Washington DC he'll enjoys the
show he thinks this puts pressure on the
authorities he thinks supporters will
come out although there's a lot fewer of
them here in Washington D.C and of
course we know that he declared his
candidacy for the presidency back in
November last year incredibly early in
the election cycle and many people
speculated at the time the reason he was
doing it so early was because he knew
these legal troubles were coming down
the pipe and then he could claim that
this was a political prosecution and so
he knew what he was doing when he
declared for president but this will be
his third indictment since he left
office in January 2021 and he will be
here in court in under an hour right and
Alan we've just seen the man himself
make the short Journey down from the uh
this Trump aircraft into a very large
car which as you said is heading in your
direction on a very short uh Drive of
course an event like this given the
amount of time that the police there in
Washington DC have been given to plan
for this situation it must be a huge
headache for the authorities the city
must be on edge around this one
well actually there's a Feeling very
relaxed atmosphere here that's because
with the exception of January the 6th
in 2021 Washington DC knows how to
prepare for big events like this and
that they get a bit of notice then they
can lock things down they can put
security plans in place and clearly Jack
Smith and his office was talking uh to
the sheriffs who guard the courthouse to
the Secret Service to the local police
to make sure that this goes as smoothly
as possible and certainly the protesters
who are largely on the other side of the
courthouse have been good-natured as
they were largely in Miami you'll
remember in Miami at the mirror there
told us that we're preparing for a crowd
of anything between five thousand and
fifty thousand in the end there was
probably about a thousand people who
turned up most of them Trump supporters
a few voices of descent here that ratio
has probably flipped there are a few
Trump supporters but there are a lot
more people who want to see Donald Trump
in court because of course many people
believe that the worst thing that Donald
Trump did during his entire presidency
was incite a crowd for January the 6th
now he's not in charge in not being
charged with incitement but the charges
that he faces here all relate to what
happened in January the 6th and the
attempt to overturn the will of the
American people in the 2020 presidential
election to stop the peaceful transition
of power which of course had been a
staple since the start of the Republic
in the 1700s and Alan of course
obviously no defense has been launched
yet we only have the indictment but
Trump's team not happy this is all
happening in Washington
that's right there will be legal
arguments that will be made at some
point in the future we may even hear a
few of them in the courthouse today but
there is a suggestion from the Trump
team that they will put forward the idea
that West Virginia would be a better uh
location for Donald Trump certainly it's
a more conservative State uh but that's
likely to be thrown out uh by the judge
in the case here simply not going to to
to fly there will be other legal moves
the Trump's legal team have hinted that
they will issue subpoenas to people that
they believe were involved in what
happened in January 6th maybe going as
far as opinion Joe Biden himself now
they've got to go in front of a judge
and argue why those are relevant so a
lot of these will be thrown out but that
will delay things and of course many
people believe that that's the whole
point of Donald Trump's defense that he
wants to delay and delay and delay not
just the case in New York but also the
case in Miami in the case here and
Washington because if he delays it
enough if you look at the polls he may
have been indicted three times impeached
twice but he is still ahead in the
Republican nomination battle to win
their presidential nomination and he
believes that if he wins the election
then he can appoint an attorney general
and run a department of justice that
makes all of this disappear and so it is
all about delayed delayed delay but we
know that Jack Smith kept the indictment
very clean very short indicted only one
person even though there are six uh
unnamed co-conspirators although we know
the names of about five of them so that
this could go to a jury very quickly and
would be presented in a very simple
fashion so that people could understand
what was being accused what they
believed Donald Trump did and of course
Jack Smith will be as the special
prosecutor looking for a guilty verdict
on Donald Trump and there are many
people in Washington DC who hope that
happen before the presidential election
uh that is coming up Alan many thanks
for that we'll be back with you shortly
but let's cross now to shehab ratanzi
who's also near the court there in
Washington DC and uh shehab
um
obviously given all the controversy
surrounding Donald Trump uh what is the
atmosphere like there are there
supporters of trump are there those
opposed to him what's the mood like
well I think with with a view to
actually get getting to talk to one of
the supporters to Donald Trump they're
very few protesters here generally
though probably about half a dozen dozen
basically and so each protester is
swarmed by the media as soon as they
found we have John Johnson here traveled
from the Jersey sure why are you here
today she supported American hero
president is an America first president
he's a constitutional supporter and he's
the best thing that's ever happened in
the American political system what do
you think of the indictments though
that's just another sham the only thing
I'm looking forward to is the Trump
Bumpy's gonna get in the polls thank you
Jack Smith just like we had in Miami
just like we had in New York a couple
months ago I'll probably go up another
four or five maybe six points in the
polls after today but isn't trying to
get us a set of quite fake electors
isn't that against the Constitution it's
the same thing Al Gore did in 2000 same
thing John Kerry did in 2004 same thing
in the Clinton crime family did in 2016.
better remember in this country the most
Fair accurate legit election this
country has ever had was 2016. the
Democrats were caught off guard they
thought they didn't have to cheat as bad
as they usually do so they let it ride
and they underestimated the heartbeat of
America the heartbeat of America is
wherever Trump got a vote in this
country it's the most accurate legit
election ever done the Democrats had to
come up with his Crossfire hurricane
made up novels that was Russia Gates
Russia gate Russia Russia Russia what
happened to the John Durham report
you're a journalist what happened it was
all debunked was it all debunked was 90
of it debunked or was 100 of IT
department I'll answer for 100 of it was
debarked the Deep State and the Clinton
crime family they concocted this whole
Russian collusion nonsense and it got
smashed back in her face John thank you
very much I know you want to get I think
Donald Trump is approaching so I know
you want to get your place so thank you
very much yeah we're looking forward to
him coming back through Trump is the
only guy that can save America thank you
John
um so yeah I mean that
and very few professors here as I said
uh but obviously this you know we were
tipped off by this enormous Trump flag
over here uh then there are also others
here as well I mean there's a chap over
here clearly with a Donald Trump with a
Hitler mustache lock the traitor up
there you can see
um but really like 12 maybe slightly
more protesters here and you've got to
remember though I mean the latest polls
show a majority Republicans 60 70 do
think that the election was stolen by
Joe Biden uh so you know you may think
oh oh gosh you know this trap yeah he
sounds you know he sounds like he's On
The Fringe he's not actually that is
actually Republican party thinking right
now
leave all right she had many thanks for
that
Let's cross back to Alan Fisher
who's at the federal courthouse and Alan
uh some interesting points made by uh
shehab's uh guest there you know given
that three in ten Americans believe that
the 2020 election was stolen I mean the
legal system in its entirety
um is really going to be put on an awful
lot of strain to show that it can uh can
can stand fast throughout all of this
well of course when Donald Trump was
impeached for what happened in January
the sixth many Republicans particularly
in the Senate said we're not going to
vote to to impeach him to to ban him
from office for the future because there
are other legal measures available and
Donald Trump had left office by that
time by the time the hearings came
around and then of course when they
bring up these now separate legal
proceedings they say this is outrageous
that Donald Trump should face this sort
of legal action uh joining me now is
Melanie Stone a former Federal
prosecutor Melanie this is is going to
be a tough case to prove isn't it for
Jacksonville because although he's laid
it out pretty clearly in a 45-page
indictment he's still got to convince
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt to 12 members
of a jury that this is what Donald Trump
was thinking when he did what he did yes
absolutely it's all going to come down
to Donald Trump's intent the indictment
goes through in chapter and verse all of
the conversations that Donald Trump was
having with legislators around the
country trying to convince them not to
certify the election it also mentions a
bunch of unindited co-conspirators and
all of their efforts to help Trump stay
in power but in the end what it's going
to come down to is that Jack Smith is
going to have to prove that Donald Trump
knowing knew that he had lost the
election and was deliberately trying to
overturn the results of the of the
election in any event one of his
defenses is that well my lawyers told me
I could do this now you used to be a
lawyer if you told me to to do something
I would probably do it because I would
trust you is that a good defense that is
not a good defense that does not work in
general in criminal justice law that my
lawyers told me to do it and besides
that that is also why all of his lawyers
are unindicted did co-conspirators
because all of those lawyers also seem
to have known this was not true I mean
there are places in the indictment where
Giuliani says you know well we'll find
the votes later so they knew that it
wasn't true and they knew that they were
telling Trump uh just what he wanted to
hear and at the same time Trump was also
hearing from many many senior advisors
that he had lost the election we've
already heard that even his own daughter
Ivanka Trump talked in front of the
January 6 committee about the fact that
she'd had a conversation telling her dad
that he'd lost the election but many
many top officials whom Mr Trump
personally appointed like farmer
Attorney General William Barr told him
that he'd lost the election so it's
going to be very hard for him to say he
didn't know he lost the election when he
had so many people telling him he lost
the election now one of the defenses is
going to be well I was fully entitled to
see this the first amendment allows me
to say that I can't see that there's an
infringement in that to me that sounds
like a defense that you're going to use
on appeal rather than something that you
use in the courtroom here would that be
fair I certainly think that this case
will be going up on appeal there's
really no question that were Trump to be
convicted this would be a case that was
immediately appealed and ultimately the
Supreme Court will have to weigh in on
this
um
so there will be those first amendment
arguments but I think that Donald Trump
will argue that right at trial he'll say
hey I was just talking and I'm I have my
right to free speech and and there may
be some jurors who are persuaded by that
but that's why Jack Smith will be making
a very careful case uh day in and day
out about the fact that Trump knew he
lost the election and that he talked to
people about having lost the election
and that he tried to stay empowered
despite losing the election let me ask
you something that a lot of people who
don't live in America have asked me if
Donald Trump is convicted that's not
disqualifying he can still run for
president what is America Thinking by
allowing that to happen
we just haven't been in this position
before so it was very hard to imagine uh
Trump has been Norm breaking from the
beginning
um the only way you cannot be uh you
cannot be allowed to serve is if you are
impeached and so um that was a big
mistake by the Senate Republicans last
time after the uh after the election
after January 6 where they decided not
to convict him in the impeached second
impeachment trial and I think they did
that because Senator Mitch McConnell
thought he'd just go away and this would
be better for America but of course
anybody who watches Donald Trump knows
he never just goes away
um and you know another thing that I
think is important for people to
recognize that if this matter isn't
settled and Mr Trump actually is elected
as president there is an opinion by the
office of legal counsel the part of the
Department of Justice that's called The
Justice Department's brain that has said
that Trump uh if he's indicted and the
case hasn't gone to trial the case will
have to go away you cannot be indicted
and tried while you are a sitting
president so it's possible they could
toll the k space meaning delay it till
after he's out of the presidency but
that's not very likely in large part
it's much more likely that all of this
just disappears which may be part of why
Trump is still running for president if
he runs for president all of his
criminal entanglements if he were to win
they all drop away and otherwise he
could be convicted and face jail time
Melanie thanks very much for joining us
live here the views of a formal Federal
prosecutor I know Donald Trump should be
making his way into the courtroom very
shortly it's a short drive from Reagan
National Airport here to the center of
Washington DC he will then be processed
fingerprints will Taken he'll have to
give his name and his social security
number and then enter the courtroom
where the charges on this latest
indictment will be read to him and he
will be asked to enter a plea which we
fully expect to be not guilty
all right Alan many thanks for that and
thanks also to Melanie Sloane Let's
cross over to Heidi Joe Castro who's
standing by because we believe Donald
Trump is inching ever closer to the
courthouse
Heidi
um none of this needed to actually
happen in person
sorry go ahead no but you know know he
it's no surprise that he is appearing in
person and we're expecting him to be in
one of these vehicles that's passing
behind me this is sort of the back side
of the courthouse where we were just
talking to Alan and these police cars
are part of the motorcade that are
escorting the former president uh from
the the nearby airport they're expected
to make this round this corner and then
most likely they will go into an
underground garage so you may not see
Trump himself at all you may see him
drive by as we're speaking here but you
can see the level of security it really
ramped up in the last hour or two as his
arrival was imminent I'm actually
squeezed between uh two dump trucks
these are parked here there's about a
dozen of them blocking access on this
block and just in this little like
window between two Park dump trucks they
have two police officers with Washington
DC metropolitan police force guarding
this Gap they have secret service for
for their back every single second and
every single step of this choreographed
arrival of the former president planned
down to the last instant and of course
here are more of those uh trucks and
you're seeing as you're seeing the Press
also waiting for his arrival we'll go
back to him we'll go back to his arrival
if we see him but I wanted to actually
bring in a resident from D.C among the
dozens or so who are here annika's so so
glad that you can join me why is being
here to see the president the former
president face these charges why is that
important to you
um I think the fact that we're willing
to hold our elected leaders accountable
is something that's really important to
me I think that we were all so many
Americans were raised on the idea of
democracy and I think that's an idea
that we're straying away from honestly
so I think that it's really important to
really stand here and stand by the
justice system Annika there's so much
controversy regarding this indictment
we've heard from some pro-trump
supporters who are here but why do you
want to see this prosecution happen
I want to see prosecution happen because
honestly I think that Trump is a threat
to our democracy and I think he's a
threat to a lot of democracies around
the world and I think that proving that
he is guilty is something that's going
to be really important for our global
politics all right thank you so much
Annika and again we are still waiting
for the president the ex-president
himself to be arriving along the
motorcade Rabbi actually just dropped my
call with you I cannot hear you if
you're speaking to me so I will back up
in case we see the president the
ex-president pass by in the moments to
come
okay Heidi um many thanks for that so as
Heidi was saying Donald Trump has now
arrived at the courthouse he's been
driven
into an underground garage we believe
that the entire procedure will take
place in a lower floor room unclear as
yet whether we will ever actually see
any images from that uh proceeding it is
of course the opportunity the chance for
Trump to hear the charges being read out
and we expect the former president to
also plead guilty or not guilty back to
Alan Fisher now who's outside that
Washington DC federal courthouse and of
course Alan all of this is taking place
only a few few blocks away from my well
I guess I suppose is the the scene of
the crime
that's right Capitol Hill not that far
away from from where I'm standing uh
within a quick 15-minute walk and you'd
be there and actually I've heard a few
people in the crowd saying that they
were here on January the 6th there was
actually someone saying that they came
along intending to be part of a peaceful
process but got caught up in what had
happened and they were pointing the
finger very much at Donald Trump and
that of course is what Jack Smith is
doing saying that he's not gone as far
as charging him with inciting the Kraut
but he's suggesting that what happened
on January the 6th and we saw that in
his comments on Tuesday evening when he
paid tribute to those who defended the
capital that they did that because of
the atmosphere that that Donald Trump
had created so it's perhaps a tactical
decision on Jack Smith the special
prosecutors part not to charge him with
incitement or Insurrection because that
would have made this a much more
difficult case case to prove joining me
now here is John Ferry who's a a
Republican strategist John incredibly
having been indicted three times
impeached twice Donald Trump's still
leading the Republican race why are the
Republicans so in love with this guy who
if you look at the real figures didn't
do a brilliant job when he was in the
White House well if you look at the
economy he did pretty well and if you
look at kind of looking out for the
interests of his voters he did very well
and they had a special bond with him
they look at all these prosecutions as
persecution they think that it's the
Washington establishment who is going
after Donald Trump because he
represented their interests and the
other thing this has done this is this
has really made it very very difficult
for any other candidate to run against
Donald Trump because he's taking all of
the air out of the balloon you know no
one's talking about Rhonda Sanders no
one's talking about Tim Scott no one's
talking about Mike Pence only to talk in
the context of where they are on Donald
Trump and so Trump is dominating the
discussions each one of these
prosecutions where he's saying this is a
persecution to me I'm trying to look out
for your interests and they're tearing
me down this has helped him with
Republican voters and it must be hard if
you're running against Donald Trump in
the Republican primary that a lot of
your message has got to be what the
front runner is saying that Donald Trump
uh was the victim of a stolen election
Donald Trump should not be charged in
the federal court this is the total
difficulty that these DeSantis and
others are are having is trying to
figure out a way to lay a glove on
Donald Trump with all these other things
going on with all these prosecutions
going on you can make the case that
Donald Trump was did a terrible job on
covid you can make the case that he
didn't really look out for the interest
of the people when they shut down
schools but it's hard to make that case
when all these lawsuits are coming all
these prosecutions coming out and then
this is the only thing that you're asked
asked about Donald Trump are these are
these prosecutions fair and what are you
going to say you can't say they are fair
uh because they're that alienates the
Republican base if you do say that
you're like Mike Pence you're at the
bottom of the polls so you know this is
a very difficult for any Republican to
gain any traction on the stuff that they
want to talk about and they what they
don't want to talk about is endlessly
Donald Trump and but that's what they're
forced to talk about because that's how
all of us are talking about it's either
Donald Trump or Taylor Swift okay but
can you run a presidential campaign with
on grievance by just saying look what
they're doing to me can you do that all
the time because in dependent voters are
going to go enough already well we'll
find out
um yeah you can run campaign based based
on grievance as a matter of fact Andrew
Jackson ran a campaign on the the
corrupt bargain way back in the 1820s
and he was able to win overwhelmingly
yeah grievance is not a a bad way to run
Richard Nixon ran against grievance in
1968.
um really in many ways Ronald Reagan ran
on gravens in 1980. you know grievance
is not a bad way to get motivated voters
to come out they vote on dislike more
than like often times
people scared to attack Donald Trump
because they realize most of the
Republican base are now Trump supporters
is this something
that they should have dealt with eight
years ago when he was running because
they knew what Donald Trump was like
they knew he lied they knew he had
business failures they knew he was
unreliable well they they tried to make
all those attacks in 19 2016. I mean
what what Trump has is a special bond
with the Trump voters who make up
probably 40 to 45 percent of the
Republican base which is a really good
base to start off from if you want to
run for a nomination and what happened
in 2016 we had so many other candidates
running against them not unlike what's
going on right now that it was hard for
anyone to get anywhere close to which
went from Pat so yeah it is very
difficult to attack Trump because you're
attracting the Trump voter and what you
have to do is try to make the
distinction between the Trump voter and
their Grievances and Donald Trump and
his special issues that he's got and
none of the other candidates are going
to step aside for one of the other
candidates become the anti-trumper are
they they're not going to say we choose
you rather than me well you know there's
a lot of ego involved and what typically
happens in these type of campaigns is
people decide not to run when they run
out and run a lot of money so in many
ways the funders will make a decision
okay who is the candidate we most want
to be the anti-trump and we're all going
to put our money in that right now you
have Rhonda said let's raise a lot of
money Tim Scott's raised a lot of money
Nikki Haley has raised a lot of money
and so they're they're and Vivek Vivica
has some money too so you know which if
you have all these guys still getting
access to money they can still run a
campaign but you're right ego is a
really big thing all these people are
voting really believe that they're the
best one to solve the problems in the
country and it's going to be hard for
them to drop out unless they're forced
to but you don't win a presidential
election on Republican voters alone
you've got to appeal to the middle those
things like appearing in a federal
courthouse accused of conspiracy and
obstruction and this is just one of
three Char three places where he's
facing these sort of I mean the
independence and mutual voters suddenly
go this guy isn't from Miami well you
know Donald Trump's not the only one
with ethical problems if you look at
what's going on with Hunter Biden and
Joe Biden and the Biden crime families
Republicans look at all allegations oh
well they're a little bit more than
allegations
nothing's really been well okay there's
a lot of smoke in the bite and fire and
uh they're going to have to make a
determination whether they like the the
Biden families problems or the Trump's
family's problems no one's coming in
with Clean Hands uh and independent
voters if you look at it with the polls
Donald Trump right now is doing better
with independent voters than people
thought he would be and the polls are
extremely tight and so this idea that if
we vote for Donald Trump he'll lose
again which is the electability argument
that Rhonda Sanchez and others are
trying to make it's not holding water
according to the polls so we'll see what
happens take your Republican hat off for
a moment as an American do you despair
that this is happening that we're seeing
what could be the most important
significant trial in American history
being carried out because of the actions
of a former president you know what I
what I I look at this this atmosphere
and it's kind of a circus I don't really
like politics becoming a circus I also
like Alexis to be decided not by lawyers
but by voters uh and I you know I think
that there there's an effort here to
derail the Trump campaign through these
prosecutions I think that there's
efforts to go after the Biden on some of
these things I would like the voters to
decide and I don't really want lawyers
to sign that's a good place to leave it
thanks very much indeed for joining us
live here in Washington DC so Donald
Trump is now in the courthouse we know
what the process will be he knows what
the process will be he's been through
this several times fingerprinted gives
over his name his address his occupation
and his social security number he will
then join his legal team in the
courthouse there will be no mug shot for
Donald Trump this time around there are
enough pitchers in the public domain for
him and then he will appear in court
when he'll be asked how he pleads to the
four charges against him and we're fully
expecting that for him to say not guilty
Alan many thanks to that and as you
heard Alan say they're an important
moment for the ex president Donald Trump
and of course it's brought both
pro-trump supporters and anti-trump
protesters to the courthouse
relatively calm considering what took
place on January the 6th 2021 at
Insurrection at the capital of course
Donald Trump accused of overturning the
2020 election results an act that
inspired that assault at the heart of
American democracy Now spring in Michael
isakov who joins us in our studio in
Washington DC he's an investor
investigative journalist a very warm
welcome to you uh so in many ways it
appears as if there are two trials going
on here there's what's going on in the
court of public opinion and there's what
eventually is going to play out in a U.S
courthouse and given that three out of
ten Americans still believe that this
election was stolen from them it seems
like this will be a real stress test for
the American judicial system
absolutely and we could get some pretty
early indications today this afternoon
on how that stress test is going to play
out
um
Trump is obviously going to plead not
guilty but the judge will have to
give some indication of how quickly she
wants to move on this and I think one of
the first big questions is does she
begin to set a schedule uh if not today
then in the next few days
um and and set a trial date we already
know that Trump is facing one trial
that's scheduled for March in New York
City that's on the hush money
allegations and another in uh in
Southern Florida for the Mar-A-Lago
documents case that's scheduled now for
may we don't know whether those uh trial
dates are going to hold up but here's a
third one and the judge
um a lot of attention will be on how
quickly does the judge try to move this
and you know is Trump going to have to
be in three courtrooms uh why all he's
running for president next year so
that's the first big thing to look for
the second big thing to look for is this
is a tough judge and does she set bowel
conditions that include admonitions to
Trump uh about some of his public
comments in which he seems to threaten
prosecutors and agents and others
involved in the um uh in these trials uh
he was just on a podcast the other day
in which he talked about it would be
very dangerous if he was ever sent to
jail that seemed to be uh could be
interpreted as a threat to um uh to
people working in the courthouse to the
prosecutors working on the case
um the judge could make it clear that
she's not going to tolerate that but
that's going to run up against Trump's
rights as a political candidate to say
whatever he wants about what the Biden
Administration justice department is
doing to him well what do you make of
the political theater around this
particular arraignment because Donald
Trump didn't actually need to be there
in person did he you could have done all
of this over Zoom what's his strategy
there do you think
no I think that the uh the court wanted
him there I don't think he there's a
option for just zooming in on your court
arraignment these days
um I I think this is something that is
required as part of the judicial process
and
um uh and look uh from Trump's
perspective I mean his poll numbers seem
to get better after each uh each one of
these um indictments and arraignments
um so it may be in his political
interest to have as much attention to
this uh as as he can get do you get the
sense that most Americans will want to
see how this turns out when it does go
to court before they vote in the
presidential election will it make any
difference if it does go to trial before
that key day
well that is you know one of the big
questions that hangs over this what
impact will it have politically
um how will the American public process
it it's really you know look
um the our country now is so polarized
is so divided and opinions about Donald
Trump are baked in uh for I would say
you know well over 90 percent of the
electorate we're talking about a
relatively small number of Voters
um who are going to decide the outcome
of the next election and um you know I
my sense is given that look we had a New
York Times poll the other day that
showed even after two criminal
indictments
um uh Donald Trump is tied uh with Joe
Biden 43-43 that's astounding the idea
that a twice indicted uh accused felon
uh could be competitive against the
incumbent president of the United States
how's the third one I think the the real
key and answer to this is
how does the trial proceed what is the
evidence and how much of the American
public will absorb what the evidence is
when it's presented in a courtroom one
problem is this is in federal court
there's no cameras in federal courtrooms
so the public won't get a chance to
watch the trial in real time they won't
get a chance to watch it at all they'll
have to rely on news accounts right so
that will somewhat diminish the power of
the evidence Michael also in previous
occasions where Donald Trump has been
under an awful lot of legal pressure
he's used these very public events as an
opportunity almost to to raise funds it
does raise the question of course who is
paying for all of these court cases this
is surely money he'd rather just plow
back into his campaign
well until now he's been using his
political action committee save America
to pay his legal bills and you know some
of that is really stretching the use of
politically donated funds because he was
using them not just for uh uh defending
himself in a case like this which
involves actions while he was president
but he was even using those funds to pay
his lawyers in New York cases
investigating his personal business
expenses having nothing to do with his
role as president
um so I think that there was um you know
some uh that clearly was stretching the
outer limits of campaign Finance law to
use his pack for purposes like that now
it's it appears he's going to be setting
up a legal defense fund but look at the
end of the day Donald Trump has no
problem raising money he's got these
fervent supporters out there
um who are appear willing to keep
sending writing checks and sending in
the envelope so
um I suspect at the end of the day
um he may be okay on uh on his legal
expenses
okay Michael many thanks for joining us
Michael issacoff he's the chief
investigative correspondent at Yahoo
news and co-host of skullduggery podcast